and welcoming back to the rich eisen
show to gents
who are part of a juggernaut of a
television show
um i'm keeping my children at bay out of
my home office to
bend the air the ears of the stars of
american ninja warrior 12th
season 12th season of america american
ninja warrior that is premiering on
mondays at 8 eastern
and pacific and it is a pleasure to have
back on the show akbar baja biamilla and
matt
eisemann how are you gents well we're
doing good uh
you know it's another season we're super
happy that we were able to pull it off
we almost thought we weren't able we
weren't going to be able to do it but
uh nbc did an amazing job pulling this
thing off
really as as we see the nfl uh getting
ready to start we have an appreciation
for what they did and it was kind of
fitting that the only way we could pull
this season off
we normally shoot in six cities around
the country and then end up in vegas
we went to saint louis we did it all in
about two weeks we shot at the dome at
america center
which is where the rams used to play so
rich you know it you know the space
80 000 seat dome completely empty
and no one in the crowd no one on the
sidelines
um and yet and akbar and i kept talking
about this
you'd think it would have felt empty but
the energy i think everyone was so
grateful
to be out of their homes and they knew
how fortunate we were to be able to do
this thing that we love
in the midst of the pandemic that the
energy actually was crazy it was crazy
good we were all
excited to be there we knew what it
meant to be there during this
yeah and then also to implementing that
the virtual experience
being able to pipe in the friends and
family uh
via you know the the virtual experience
and having them there to cheer them on
uh matt and i were concerned we thought
like man are we still going to be able
to
to have our enthusiasm and we did the
only thing that was tricky though
in that space 80 000 fans aren't there
so
when every time that matt and i would go
back and forth
the competitors could hear our
commentary and so although
so they knew everything we were saying
oh if fans think joe buck is biased wait
till aaron rodgers
stops the middle in the middle of a play
goes joe what are you talking about here
i can hear you
i can hear you pulling against green bay
i can hear
every word you're saying so that's
is that right some of the competitors
like as they they actually one of them
said hey akbar tell me another way i
could screw up this obstacle i'm on
but we're not going to be jim nance rich
we're not going to be in there
oh you'll find approach here that's
right we're not going to whisper
we thought about doing it we thought
about doing it but we thought nah that's
not that's not the ninja flavor yeah
yeah no i've got to do that at the
combine which is the only other
uh experience i would ever have about
having an event in a
virtually empty stadium you know like
there's you just hear
you know the the hum of the air
conditioning unit in the place
yeah and a bunch of the beeps the
stopwatches every two seconds it's like
a laboratory
and heavy breathing right so i would
always you know but it would be some
action like someone like i mean when
somebody runs a great 40-yard dash
so i kind of had to do a little bit of
that nance golf voice you know i got to
keep why
why though i've always wanted that rich
you know i cause it's again like
well first of all you never want tom
coughlin staring at you to keep it down
like that's number one
okay that's it that's the first thing
you never want that tom conference stare
of like who the hell is screaming i'm
trying to figure out what my
right tackle is going to be with his
10-yard dash time you know
his split and and it's just i don't know
there's kind of like a zen
quality to it but obviously your action
does not lend
to anything but the way that you you
know and we did we ended up we had a lot
of discussions we ended up putting a
little bit of crowd noise in
and some of it was the actual friends
and family cheering um
but there were two reasons we did it one
was akbar and i
when we're going were very loud but for
us it was actually helpful to have that
crowd noise because
it helps kind of guide our energy as
well but i think also
for the ninjas and it's something that
you know i've been watching sports and
rich i'd be interested to hear your take
on it knockbar you too
but i i think some of the reasons these
young guys like morikawa
on the pga i i think it's probably been
easier for them
to come out and play without the crowds
because the crowds i think will get your
energy going and if you don't know how
to handle it
i i think it's a different beast but but
for some of the athletes i think they
miss it they miss that
adrenaline rush and and and it's i i
think it's
it's different but i think it is tougher
for the athletes to perform and
but aren't you know our ninjas really it
was just breathtaking
the performances we saw and i think that
again the gratitude to be there really
propelled them to these
unbelievable performances and man i'll
say this and i i've truly felt this i
know we haven't had the pre-season
and the the nfl have had kind of you
know the inner squad scrimmages and
stuff like that
but there's nothing that replaces you
know having
the fans and some stadiums will allow uh
two thousand three thousand four
thousand but
that's not the same look i played at san
diego state no not to to my alma mater
but i know what it's like to play
in a big stadium with not that many fans
and when you make a big play you're so
intoxicated by the the energy and you're
so used to that and when you don't have
that
i mean it can bring the level down i
mean and so learning how to manage the
expectations
of of the crowd and the atmosphere is
going to be another
obstacle i think for a lot of these
athletes because none of them have
really probably played unless
they played at a small school those are
probably going to be the only athletes
who can make the quick adjustment yeah i
mean
married steve mariucci was just
mentioning this this comment
uh he mentioned it to us as we were
getting ready for game day morning
preview show this week on nfl network
that
that the players that are about to play
in the nfl
season that even some of their
youth football games with all the
parents there
might have more fans at those games than
the ones that you're about to play in
some of yeah stadiums like
forget about college and forget about
even high school
like youth soccer like youth football
games youth uh you know pop warner games
have more screaming parents added
some of these stadiums that will have no
fans in it but crowd noise pumped in
it's going to be a weird thing i think
so i think the first week
because i imagine the players have been
through what we've all been through
being locked down and
granted they've been in some training
camps and or you know at least
practices now right they're around each
other but i think there's going to be
something about them where they felt
they knew this season was in jeopardy
and they've seen how
basketball has struggled and they've
done it but baseball's having their
having their knocks
and i i think all of america is ready
for football to come back so i think the
first few games
are going to be crazy but mid-season
unless we start seeing crowds come back
it'll be interesting right to
see you know cam newton in new england
with with total silence when instead of
well i mean now he's gonna be you won't
think it's crazy cam newton week two is
gonna be in seattle with no crowd noise
oh
it's just gonna be a fascinating thing
and it's it's it's interesting how you
were pointing out what
your athletes and your competitors and
american ninja american ninja warrior
went through i got matt eisemann and
akbar baja biamilla here matt you're
wearing your broncos lid
yeah uh von miller oh don't even bring
it up rich why are you gonna do this
kind of have to
it looks like he's hard that he's gonna
be done for the year here
it's just heartbreaking and he's like
he's a game changer and i think not just
on the field i think as
a leader too and to lose that presence
is gonna be tough especially
because i think the offensive side is is
going to be interesting with locking a
lot of new talent but
not having a defense on lockdown when
you just you mentioned it
i mean mahomes and the chiefs were all
going to be playing
catch up to them i think for a long time
so the afc west
uh uh i know your raiders are the same
that's my guy right there but you know
what i mean that's just that's just
better for my raiders
that's one team we don't have to worry
about it would be interesting to see
what melvin gordon looks like in uh
as a bronco i'm really curious to see
how he fits into that run scheme
well what about the raiders i was just
saying that on the show this week akbar
that that's one of the teams i
i have no earthly idea they went seven
and nine last year
and they can be three four games better
and be a surprise you know competitor
for the
chiefs in the west or a completely
different story how do you see the
vegas raiders play that well the vegas
raider i think there's going to be that
energy from being in a new place new
team
but i'm not quite sure myself look we
there's not a lot of film right now to
see
you know how they've improved outside of
some of the reports and some of the
things that you get
in and out but uh i do believe in i'm
still a big believer in john gruden and
his ability to get those guys
um systematically they've added some new
pieces as well
um i thought marcus mariota was really
gonna be a big push
uh to derek carr it doesn't sound like
the word coming out of the camp that
that's
been the case um but i really do believe
that mark
derek card needs that push somebody who
can keep him kind of on his edge because
we saw
what two three years ago when he kind of
blew up and we were going oh
there's something here and since then
we've seen a little bit of a regression
but
you know regression to me doesn't mean
that you can't pop back up
uh so i don't know to be to be quite
honest this is the one year i can say
that even though as a fan as a former
player i'm optimistic about the raiders
i just don't know enough about what the
raiders are built up too
what a loss with that new stadium
opening i know
because that i think would have been one
of the best places look the broncos are
going to play it there every season
and my friends and i already had that on
the schedule we were going to go
there and i i think for for them to be
in to be in a new place
and not have any crowd energy there for
a team that i think
was ready to be embraced in vegas i
think that that'll be really tough for
them too
well what i love as a broncos fan well i
i will say this i'm going to break some
news here on your show
rich are you ready akbar yes okay i am
actually in the process
of trying to uh get fans back into
the stadium so i have had nothing but
time during the quarantine
what you got two months shark tank stuff
here rich get ready
okay this is what's gonna get fans back
in
i've designed this feature right here
it's like a milestone to get into the
game and you can also look at that
you can eat i've got the patent on it
got a provisional patent on this thing
so you see this right here it breathes
well anti-fog
and it allows you to be able it's got
filters here you can see the filter
there
you can see the filter there i want fans
back in the stands
so a player and as an announcer yeah i
can't imagine not having that energy
so i've already been on the phone with
the spanos um so we've had conversations
okay
talk to the league office i'm trying to
get this pumped out
i'm trying to get a partnership with
with big companies right now
be able to mass produce this so i've
been getting the conversation
rolling so hopefully not this probably
won't happen for this for the nfl
football season but perhaps for the
college football season
you'll see my my mask out there the
cookie barra mask
i have some follow-ups um
yep go ahead i'm ready um this is a
shark tank on rich isaac that's it
i don't know i know i by the way uh if i
was a shark i'd be
interested in investing um you you
it's an interesting idea uh what do we
call it what do we have cover two mask
the covered mask cover two
one now but but the whole concept of
again
here's a follow-up the whole concept
again for the radio audience that it
opens up like right around above the
mouth and the chin
goes down and opens up a clear path to
the mouth for your hot dog your nachos
your best friend what have you
but doesn't that also allow whatever air
you're trying to keep
out uh in or out doesn't that now
don't we have a problem here do we have
oh yeah there you go and so i spoke with
the
the infectious disease specialist for
the cdc and this was some of the
concerns that they had but the
idea is that you're not necessarily
going to stop everything a hundred
percent
yes but it does minimize so there's an
automatic
uh retraction so as soon as you pull it
down and you eat it goes right back
up it's extended from the face and this
allows you to eat and chew
now yes there is a little bit of
exposure once you
you have it but everyone's not going to
be eating at the same time
and while you're eating everything is
contained so those respiratory droplets
aren't going because what we do know
right now is that when you're yelling
that's when all of those respiratory
droplets are just moving and you have a
cloud
of those potential covet 19 floating in
the air
so i guess everything contained so i
guess as long as nobody's yelling
while eating we're in good shape that's
great
you found the one weakness those yellow
eaters that's going to be physical
how are you going to like like joey
chestnut
joey chestnut will not be allowed in the
rainbow
no cover two in coney island
on july 4. i'm gonna say uh rich i've
known akbar now
for i guess it's eight eight nine years
this guy is one of the hardest working
guys
he came up with this on his own this
this really is an idea that that spawned
from
him and his passion for getting people
back in so i
if he lets me i'm going to be i'm going
to be the first shark in i bet
all right i'll be i'll be this won't
have cubans money it'll be like a
mcdonald's gift certificate
i guess my last question for you matt is
what do you have in your man cave that
can help save the universe do you have
anything in there
what do you got okay this
it's a mad iceman head on a stick is the
doctor
i got so excited this is for those who
remember the jetsons do you remember
jane jensen would get on and she just
put this up
yes i didn't shower today i might have
had something now rich now i'm tv ready
look at that that's blue blocks my
respiratory droplets
it's my head on a stick for the radio
audience
and who doesn't have their head on this
day oh my i i wish i had something
i got uh you've got even better you've
got yourself running a 40 in a
silhouette is your logo that's outside
you have that that is amazing for me
hey guys it's always a blast having you
on it's great to see american ninja
warrior back you know i hear all the
time hey it's so great to have the nfl
back it's great to have
you guys back my family it's must-see tv
you can see past seasons on peacock you
can also check out
american ninja warrior on monday nights
um
for for the foreseeable future and i
thanks for doing it always
we appreciate it that's awesome thank
you you got it that's akbar baja
biamilla and also matt heisman here
on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here